on avait des ganglions tout temps et
flammes aient l'impression que ma peau
était trop tard du pour mon corps
perdues cheveux dépression accepté ce
soir une enquête choc sur les dangers
potentiels des implants mammaires et est
restée maladies auto immunes pipo et
signent pas si j'avais su que j'étais un
cobaye
jamais je n'aurais une implantée depuis
des décennies ont dit aux femmes que les
implants sont sans danger pour la santé
mais est ce vraiment le cas j'ai jamais
du mal à l'avant mais un plan b g un
cancer fabriqué par des humains
madeleine roy et martin bordeaux avec la
collaboration du consortium
international des journalistes d'
enquêtes ont documenté des faits
troublants
quand j'ai compris qu'il y a vraiment
une maladie associée aux atlantes
je ne pouvais pas éthiquement continuer
d'en poser et milliers d'incidents liés
aux implants monde était cachée le
laxisme de santé canada est inquiétant
c'était comme une panne ex mari corps
est fou je m'efface enlevés
veut pas mourir bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
c'est dans quelques minutes
we came as tu sens la trêve va bien
aller jones m
groleau attend ce moment depuis
longtemps c'est mon seul espoir c'est ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas goûté à
l'espoir
depuis trois ans m et l'ombre
d'elle-même elle est persuadée que ces
implants mammaires l'ont rendue malade
j'ai pas le contrôle sur mon physique
j'ai par contre eu son moment talk et
gti parle fonctionner la vendent
j'oubliais jamais rien j'ai toutes mes
affaires est organisé mais n'en fut tout
le contraire de tout est dit au revoir à
sa mère pour se rendre à la salle
d'opération une chirurgienne américaine
va lui retirer ses implants ce soit
c'est mon espoir de retrouver une
certaine qualité de vie
elles ont 30 40 50 ou 20 ans elles sont
travailleuse sociale maquilleuse femme
d'affaires ou championne de
conditionnement physique comme des
centaines de canadiennes elles affirment
que leurs implants mammaires les ont
rendus malades alors que leur médecin et
santé canada leur avaient laissé
entendre qu'ils étaient sécuritaires
[Musique]
depuis qu en 1889 au chirurgien
téméraire a eu l'idée d'injecter de la
paraffine dans la poitrine de ses
patientes
les fans ont servi de cobayes pour
toutes sortes d'expérimentations un tour
de poitrine généreuse devient
particulièrement un critère de beauté
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale dans
les années 40 en injecte un mélange de
graisses et de silicone directement dans
la poitrine des femmes dans les années
50 en implante des éponges de plastique
on essaie aussi les bandelettes de
polymères les résultats sont désastreux
en 1962
timmy jean l'elysée une mère de famille
américaine est la première à recevoir
une prothèses de silicone semblables à
celles qu'on trouve aujourd'hui sur le
marché
peu de temps après on invente les
prothèses salines leur enveloppe est
faite de silicone mais elles sont
remplies de sérum physiologique 50 ans
et des millions de chirurgie plus tard
l'innocuité des implants mammaires fait
toujours l'objet de controverses
aujourd'hui catherine clairement bastien
est une des principales influences aux
québécoises en matière d'entraînement et
de mode de vie santé la championne de
bikini fitness a eu des implants
mammaires pendant trois ans trois ans de
trop que vous aimez les trop de
concentration la paire de mémoire et les
bandeaux noirs et provin des farc a
secoué et ce non des symptômes que
beaucoup de porteuses d'implants
mammaires comme julie connaissent bien
souvent je me réveille le matin avec les
mêmes rêves enfler les piètrement flip
mon visage est en fait en permanence
l'impression que ma peau était trop tard
du poumon quand j'avais des ganglions
tout le temps un flow libre de cheveux
dépression accepté j'avais des rh sur ma
peau mes articulations
tout me faisait mal réfection récurrents
j'avais dit rien écrire comme si j'avais
un crime en permanence diagnostic d'ars
en 2014 alors que je très sportive
jamais fini beaucoup progressé aussi
j'ai arrêté de transpirer et je n'ai
plus de transpirer pendant 10 à la
fatigue
c'était plus que de la fatigue site est
un maillon d'exhaure chuté et put s
épuiser complètement
julie avait des implants de silicone eve
et catherine des implants salins les
trois femmes sont persuadés qu'ils ont
souffert de la maladie des implants
mammaires une maladie dont leur
chirurgien ne leur avait pas parlé non
il m'a conseillé de les faire changer au
bout de dix ans il y avait aucun
problème y avait aucun risque
c'est ce si l'implant rupture
le quai est absorbée par ton corps les
risques de maladies auto immunes les
risques d'inflammation de fatigue
extrême des poèmes par la maladie des
implants mammaires n'est pas
officiellement reconnue
on parle pourtant de ce phénomène depuis
30 ans ce sont des histoires comme celle
de julie dave et de catherine qui ont
mené dans les années 90 à un moratoire
sur les implantations icônes et à
d'énormes recours collectif contre les
manufacturiers
ils ont vendu des implants mammaires qui
n'était pas sécuritaire alors on épaules
des rats de laboratoire des cobayes les
symptômes d'hier étaient sensiblement
les mêmes que ceux d'aujourd'hui
je ne peux pas dormir j'ai mal on a mal
sous les bras tu as mal dans les bras
comme un bandeau et les médecins d'hier
était tout aussi dépourvu devant le
phénomène que ceux d'aujourd'hui
c'est venu aux questions écologiques que
c'était dans ma tête que ça se passait
j'ai été voir un psychologue
effectivement on va là jamais parti
je me serais mansac un diagnostic de
dépression majeure puis le fait d'être
une femme dans la quarantaine et tu as
ouvert l'explication fourre tout le
déclic vaut ce faire sur internet
c'est quand je suis tombé sur le site de
nicole sur facebook
ça a été une révélation j'ai fais en mon
dieu c'est s'obliger tous les symptômes
coller avec les symptômes nikon daruda
nicole baroudeur est une canadienne de
colombie britannique
elle a elle même était malade avant de
faire retirer ses prothèses de silicone
depuis trois ans elle consacre tout son
temps à faire connaître la maladie des
implants son groupe privé sur facebook
compte plus de cinquante mille femmes
on y trouve des centaines de témoignages
et des liens vers des études selon
lesquelles les implants sont loin d'être
inoffensif
c'était quand même connecteur mâle gold
faut je m'efface enlevé je veux pas
mourir c'est de la folie d'appeler
partout puis qui peut le faire le plus
vite qui peut le faire le moins cher le
retrait des implants poser pour des
raisons esthétiques n'est généralement
pas couverts par l'assurance maladie
selon nos recherches faire enlever ses
implants en cabinet privé peut coûter
aussi cher que d'en faire poser entre
4000 et 12 mai le dollar
oui elle va choisi de se faire opérer en
ohio aux états unis laventure va lui
coûter 13 mille dollars canadiens
pourquoi loyaux parce qu'on y trouve la
chirurgienne lojen feignent une star de
l'explantation aux états unis la veille
de l'opération
la docteure feignent passe près de deux
heures avec eve
[Musique]
ça m'apporte une amende ou paix d'esprit
jeu
il part rassuré face à la chirurgie est
ce que tu as peur des fois qu'ils
allaient voter un plan qu'on se rend
compte que des implants sont
parfaitement sain que dans le fond des
symptômes étaient pas relié aux est plat
n'ont aucunement aucunement parce que
j'ai jamais du malade avant l'avant mais
un plan donc ça peut pas faire autrement
que ça s'améliore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eve gros lot est sur la table
d'opération depuis déjà une heure quand
on nous laisse entrer dans la salle
nous allons bientôt découvrir à quel
point une explantation est une chirurgie
délicate
c'est une très grosse capsule la
docteure loudine feng a déjà retiré un
implant il est recouvert d'une capsule
une enveloppe de tissus cicatriciels qui
se forme en réaction à la présence de
l'implant de ce ce match c'est qu'elle
est beaucoup plus épaisses ici du côté
de la cage thoracique
chez certaines patientes les capsules se
contracte avec le temps et les saints
deviennent durs et douloureux celle
d'air sont encore souple mais elles se
sont attachés aux muscles et à
l'ossature de la cage thoracique est ce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de tissu
cicatriciel sur les côtes
oui c'est pour ça qu'elle avait des
douleurs à la poitrine
elle va se sentir beaucoup mieux la
chirurgienne pense que les tissus
cicatriciels en empêchant eve de
respirer librement ont pu contribuer à
sa fatigue et à son anxiété
elle soupçonne que la toux chronique
dave était aussi causé par les tissus
cicatriciels enfin time when you quand
votre respiration n'est pas fluide
souvent vous allez tout s'est tu crois
certaines personnes ont une toux
chronique
alors on essaie d'enlever le plus de
tissus possible lou jing feng a fait des
centaines d'ex plantation est ce qu'elle
a vu et entendu l'a convaincue d'arrêter
de poser des implants olé olé quand j'ai
compris qu'il y a vraiment une maladie
associée aux implants
je ne pouvais pas éthiquement continuer
d'en poser les déclarations de la
docteure fait n'y déroge vous perçu dans
vos collègues une paria
l'opération est terminée
à la demande des ve les appelants seront
envoyés au canada pour analyse
le chimiste pierre blais à 80 ans il a
consacré une grande partie de sa vie à
dénoncer les risques liés aux implants
mammaires à la fin des années 80 il
était conseiller scientifique à santé et
bien être social canada l'ancêtre de
santé canada à l'époque certains plans
étaient recouverts d'une couche de
polyuréthane qui se désagréger dans le
corps des porteuses de prothèses ne peut
pas propre à l'implantation humaine en
1989 pierre blais recommande à ses
supérieurs de retirer ses implants du
marché non seulement on ne l'écoutent
pas mais on lui demande de détruire les
documents dans lesquels il a écrit que
les prothèses sont potentiellement
dangereuses
pierre blais a refusé de se taire et il
a été congédié pour insubordination
après 14 années de service quelques
années plus tard les prothèses décrié
par pierre blais ont été retirés du
marché
le chimiste a fondé une entreprise
spécialisée dans l'analyse de
dispositifs médicaux
il a analysé des milliers d'implants
mammaires madrane gros lot est une
personne normale à ce que touche ce
genre d'un clan
il ya deux types d'un plan les deux ont
une enveloppe de silicone certains sont
remplies de gel de silicone alors que
d'autres sont remplies de solution
saline
c'est ce type d'implant kvm depuis cinq
ans savard défectueuses sur ma propre à
66% des implants de cette famille là les
valves de remplissage des deux implants
dave n'était pas étanche
la solution saline pouvait en sortir et
les fluides corporels est entré cette
défaillance peut mener à la
contamination des implants depuis 20 ans
le chimiste en a vu de toutes les
couleurs de tels cas de contamination
sont toutefois rares
eve a été épargné l'intérieur n'est pas
lourdement contaminées et ça c'est une
bonne chose parce qu'autrement madame
rouleau sera beaucoup plus malade que le
rrq pierre blais procède maintenant à
l'analyse des capsules il découvre une
anomalie sur la capsule droite
madame rouleau avant le commencement
d'un abcès pour la la porte à droite
julie aussi a demandé à pierre blais
d'analyser ces implants elle a eu d un
plant silicone pendant onze ans dommage
de perforation pierre blais a trouvé un
trou dans l' enveloppe de naples 1-1
fendillement d'à peu près un demi
centimètre selon chimiste de l'huile de
silicone s'est échappée de l'implant
jolly pendant des années pierre bleue
n'est pas médecin mais il est persuadé
que ce qu'il a découvert pourrait avoir
perturbé le système immunitaire des v2
julie et causé une partie de leurs
symptômes
pourtant en 2006 lorsque santé canada a
levé le moratoire sur les implants
silicone il a soutenu qu hormis
certaines complications locales
les nouveaux implants était sans danger
pour la santé
on les a surnommés
comme hubert parce qu'ils avaient la
consistance des célèbres jujubes leur
gel cohésif en principe ne pouvait pas
se répandre dans le corps des porteuses
tout a été tenté pour convaincre les
clientes que les nouveaux implants était
indestructible des expériences absurde
système immunitaire est supérieur à ce
marteau d'encore le système immunitaire
va attaquer l'implant mammaire et
l'implant va faiblir dr john willem qu
une terre verte et aux chercheurs de
renommée mondiale le rhumatologue et
spécialiste des problèmes de santé liés
aux appelants silicone de silicone le
celi compte de ces implants peut migrer
vers les ganglions lymphatiques et
activer le système immunitaire
si l'activation est constante
ça peut mener à des allergies ou à des
déficiences immunitaires
ce qui veut dire que vous n'avez plus
assez d'anticorps pour combattre les
bactéries alors vous avez des infections
à répétition dont on va le couper en
matière de silicone tous les médecins ne
loge pas à la même enseigne
quand vous dites toxicité de quelque
chose peut dérégler le système
immunitaire entre dire ça et le prouver
scientifiquement ya un monde
pour le président de l'association des
spécialistes en chirurgie plastique et
esthétique du québec la maladie des
implants mammaires n'existe pas de
brosse s'implante il ne se fait plus de
15 ans 18 ans que ces deux dossiers a
été fermé là dessus et
écumez qu' on n'a pas associé ça aux
implants mammaires il est vrai qu'aucun
lien de causalité entre les symptômes
des femmes et leurs implants n'a été
établie scientifiquement mais comme la
firme la fdea afin d'exclure que ce lien
existe il faudrait faire des études
beaucoup plus vaste et longues que
celles qui ont été faites jusqu'à
présent
alors pourquoi on continue de dire
qu'ils sont sécuritaires parce qu'on a
aucune preuve qu'ils ne sont pas mais on
n'a pas la preuve qu'ils le sont c'est
un peu comme
c'est un peu comme
dans le code criminel on est innocent
jusqu'à preuve du contraire
en attendant que des études de causalité
soit faite
le docteur cohen terre verte observe ce
qui se passe après l'exploitation
nous avons fait une vaste méta analyse
qui démontre que 60 à 70 % des patientes
vont beaucoup mieux une fois que leurs
implants sont enlevés c'est convaincant
des enfants complètement la
concentration est revenue mon symptômes
majeurs à moi qui étais la sensation de
brûlure en interne la soif intense c'est
disparaît complètement
et ça n'est jamais revenu cinq mois
après l'exploitation
la partie n'est pas encore gagnée pour
eve depuis l'opération c'était difficile
parce que je pensais moi on faire opérer
et pilleurs bondir c'est un soap un fait
qui s'apprêter le corps la respiration
est plus facile les troubles de mémoire
l'anxiété et les sentiments dépressifs
sont presque disparu mais certaine
douleur et la fatigue persiste il
faudrait apprennent tout tranquillement
j'ai l'impression de sortir d'un court
moment un peu l'heure
[Applaudissements]
la maladie des implants mammaires fait
encore l'objet de débats mais en 2016
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
reconnu qu'un type d'implant pouvait
causer un cancer du système immunitaire
un cancer qui va peut être aider à mieux
comprendre le mal mystérieux dont
souffrent certaines porteuses d'implants
savez j'ai un cancer fabriqué par des
humains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non loin des berges du lac ni pissing à
north bay dans le nord de l'ontario
nous avons rencontré une femme
déterminée en 2009 des rumeurs
à 44 ans quand elle décide d'opter pour
une augmentation mammaire
je savais précisément ce que je voulais
c'était de retrouver la poitrine que
j'avais avant d'avoir mes enfants à
trois points
terry est co propriétaire d'une
compagnie de pavage elle se considère en
parfaite santé à genoa je ne manquais
pas de confiance en moi pour moi même si
c'est invasif
c'était un peu comme teindre les cheveux
gris terry raconte que son chirurgien
lui recommande d un plan de silicone à
surface texturée cette surface peut
prévenir le durcissement des capsules il
lui parle ensuite de certains risques
risques dont il m'a parlé c'est celui
qui vient avec toute chirurgie majeure
qui se fait sous anesthésie et les
risques d un plan il n'y a pas eu de
discussion sur les risques des implants
pas du tout nan
aucune tout se passe bien pendant six
ans mis à part certains changements
subtils
je regardais les photos et je trouvais
que j'avais le visage bouffi
pourtant je n'avais pas pris de points
aujourd'hui je n'en suis pas certaine
mais je crois que c'était les premiers
signes d'inflammation de réaction
immunitaire
encore réagissait aux implants en 2015 à
l'âge de 50 ans terry passe une première
mammographie de routine
une semaine plus tard j'ai pris mon mari
dans mes bras et j'ai senti une douleur
j'avais des masses dur comme débit sur
le côté de mon sein gauche est la même
au gras fille a provoqué la rupture des
deux implants terry doit subir une
chirurgie de remplacement open meilleurs
quand ils m'ont ouvert
ils ont vu que mon un plan droit était
crevé dans la capsule
du côté gauche mais ganglions été
atteint et la capsule et l'implant était
déchiré le gel de silicone était comme
dj lo dans ma poitrine
il a fallu tout nettoyer fois acheté
quelques semaines plus tard le rapport
de pathologies arrive et la vie de terry
bascule il y avait trois tumeurs
d'environ 5 centimètres chacune sur la
capsule
on pouvait voir le cancer à l'oeil nu
terry est la douzième porteuses
d'implants mammaires canadienne chez qui
on découvre un lymphome anaplasique à
grandes cellules associés aux implants
mammaires à l'été 2015 140 cas seulement
ont été identifiées à travers le monde
on sait encore très peu de choses sur ce
cancer à moi je vais sur les sites
canadiens de cancer la société
canadienne du cancer dit non on n'a
jamais entendu parler de votre cancer le
cancer est très avancé
malheureusement mon cancer de stade iv
est passé des capsules aux ganglions
children's sont développées dans
l'intestin et ont causé des lésions dans
l'estomac
malgré huit traitements de
chimiothérapie
la maladie progresse on annonce atterri
qu'il ne lui reste que quelques mois à
vivre
bada je me suis mise à chercher de
l'aide à la grandeur de la planète sur
facebook
terry se joint à un groupe de femmes qui
souffrent du même cancer quelle grâce à
leurs contacts
elle découvre traitement expérimental
qui va la sauver
j'ai eu quatre traitements de cet essai
clinique et la maladie a complètement
disparu
elle fera féraud j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie pour les femmes décédées le
diagnostic était à peine établi à peine
remise de ses traitements t8 s'engage à
aider ses soeurs d'un fortune depuis
deux ans elle a fait énormément de
recherches qui a été dévastateur pour
moi c'est d'apprendre que santé canada
les a remis sur le marché en 2006 sur la
base d'une étude menée sur moins de 1000
femmes non seulement les études de
sécurité présenté par les manufacturiers
mentor et allergan porté sur un petit
nombre de femmes mais elles n'étaient
pas terminées elle devait durer dix ans
est la plus avancée en était à sa
quatrième année déjà les résultats
étaient troublants les taux de ré
opération était élevé 24 % pour les
patientes qui avaient eu une
augmentation mammaire et 41 % pour
celles qui avaient subi une
reconstruction mammaire à la suite d'un
cancer par exemple et femmes non si
j'avais su que j'étais un cobaye et que
les études à long terme sur la sécurité
n'était pas fait
jamais je n'aurais eu un plus
en 2005
l'épidémiologiste américaine diana zouk
herman s'est battu pour empêcher les
implants en silicone de revenir sur le
marché
sauf quand la mda et santé canada ont
donné le feu vert aux manufacturiers
diana zouk herman a perdu une des plus
importantes batailles de sa carrière
j'étais anéantie je ne croyais pas que
ça pouvait arriver en 2006 santé canada
a admis le manque de données à long
terme
le ministère a donné une approbation
conditionnelle aux manufacturiers
allergan et mentor devait entreprendre
de vastes études il devait suivre
pendant dix ans
quarante mille femmes chacun j'étais
énorme sort était formidable si elle
avait été faite mais les études n'ont
jamais été terminée deux ans après avoir
commencé son étude
allergan avait perdu la trace de 40 pour
cent des participantes mentor a fait
pire après trois ans le manufacturier
avait perdu la trace de 80 pour cent des
participantes au lieu de sévir
l'afd a et santé canada ont permis aux
manufacturiers de s'en tenir à des
études de moindre envergure
une belle occasion de faire enfin la
lumière sur la maladie des implants
mammaires a été perdu
alors une de mes questions à santé
canada c'est pourquoi vous nous obligez
pas les manufacturiers à faire les
études
vous nous avez donné un faux sentiment
de sécurité et de défense
santé canada a refusé de nous accorder
une entrevue dans sa déclaration écrite
il estime que les manufacturiers ont
rempli leur condition parce qu'ils ont
fait des efforts et que la participation
des femmes échappait à leur contrôle
pour le moment santé canada n'a pas
l'intention d'exiger le retrait des
implants textures et du marché le
ministère estime qu'une porteuses
d'implants mammaires texturé sur 12000
va développer un lymphome
à ce jour 25 canadiennes ont développé
ce cancer au total 615 cas ont été
répertoriés à travers le monde
seize femmes sont décédées après la
pause on sort les caméras cachées pour
voir ce que des chirurgies et vont dire
à des femmes qui veulent d un plat
restez avec nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
5 septembre 2018 dans un hôtel de
washington 20 femmes se prépare à
rencontrer des représentants de la fbf
moi je représente et caroline j'étais
ambulancière au texas pendant 11 ans
puis la troisième génération de la
famille blessée par des implants
mammaires déjà eu un cancer du sein à
trente trois ans et j'ai développé un
lymphome un cancer créée par l'homme à
l'âge de 40 ans j'ai perdu mes seins
mais je n'ai pas perdu ma voix
terry maigreur est venue de north bay en
ontario
nicole daruda arrive de vancouver pour
parler au nom des cinquante mille femmes
qui fréquentent son groupe facebook
destinée à la maladie des implants
mammaires
c'est la première fois qu'elles se
rencontrent les femmes ont une alliée
cette informaticienne a découvert que
depuis des années des informations
cruciales concernant les implants
mammaires ont été cachés madrid
je suis une ancienne informaticienne de
l'afd à ma justome à commercialiser un
logiciel qui permet de faire des
recherches approfondies dans la base de
données publique de laives des as qui
contient tous les rapports d'événements
indésirables liés aux implants médicaux
un événement indésirable
c'est un problème qui met la santé d'un
patient en danger
en 2016 un avocat a demandé à mme ashton
de l'aider il savait qu'il y avait des
cas à propos d'un type d'implant
mammaire
il voulait que je trouve les rapports
mais il n'était pas là elles soupçonnent
que des manufacturiers ont déclaré des
accidents majeurs comme des ruptures ou
d'airé opérations dans des rapports
prévus pour des incidents mineurs
des rapports qui ne sont pas rendus
publics par craquer l'avocat s'est
adressé aux manufacturiers
aleph des as et en moins de trois mois
des centaines de rapports sont apparus
chaque mois au moins
du jour au lendemain la fdr a exigé que
les incidents et désirable majeurs
soient déclarées comme il se doit et les
statistiques ont explosé alors que
depuis 2008 la fda a publié en moyenne
230 rapport par année
concernant des problèmes liés aux
implants mammaires elle en a publié près
de 13000 en 2017 et dans la première
moitié de 2010 8
selon nos informations une partie de ces
rapports pourraient être liés à une
fraude perpétrée par deux médecins en
les soustrayant du total il demeure que
le nombre de rapports reçus par l'afd a
est passé de 20 par mois à 400 par mois
on sort on a cru pendant douze ans que
les implants était devenu plus
sécuritaire alors qu'en réalité les
problèmes n'étaient pas visibles au
canada les données raconte sensiblement
la même histoire c'est le calme plat
puis soudainement près de 600 rapport
apparaissent en 2017 2018
santé canada nous a expliqué que la
hausse était due à une modification des
pratiques de déclaration des accidents
indésirables du manufacturier mentor
malgré la hausse des déclarations ces
chiffres ne sont que la pointe de
l'iceberg pour tous les dispositifs
médicaux les manufacturiers ont
l'obligation de déclarer les incidents
et désirable majeur
heures mais pas les médecins cela fait
qu'une grande partie des problèmes ne
sont pas rapportés à la vidéo on a fait
une vérification avec le bureau de
l'inspecteur général en 2010 et on a
trouvé que seulement 14% des événements
indésirables étaient rapportés nous
avons montré les statistiques
canadiennes
amadou ce tome est donc il ya moins de
rapport au canada santé canada explique
que la sous-déclaration des accidents et
désirable est un problème chronique
connus afin d'améliorer la situation
le ministère a proposé de rendre la
déclaration obligatoire pour les
hôpitaux les nouvelles règles pourraient
être en place dès 2019
cela ne changera pas grand chose dans le
cas des implants mammaires
la majorité des interventions sont
faites en cabinet privé et non à
l'hôpital
les chirurgiens des cabinets pourront
continuer de ne pas rapporter les
incidents graves et les symptômes de la
maladie des implants tass c'est le coeur
du problème les chirurgiens refuse de
reconnaître les symptômes il ne les
inscrivent pas dans votre dossier même
quand les femmes se les fonds retirés
ils écrivent des choses comme or elle
était insatisfait de ses implants
mammaires
comment vous le savez je le fais parce
que je lis les histoires de 50 mille
femmes fait cinquante mille femmes sur
un groupe facebook destinée à la maladie
des implants sané branle pas le docteur
bensimon pourquoi on n'en parle plus
pourquoi vous trouvez des pages fait
peut-être à cause des médias sociaux
peut-être à cause d'un effet de
somatisation de masse qui est un effet
qui est connu c'est dans la tête je veux
pas dire que c'est dans leur tête parce
que c'est quand c'est dans nos têtes on
ressent pas vraiment le symptôme on
imagine mais quand somatise on peut
ressentir un symptôme 109 sans avoir de
la pathologie où le problème
le docteur éric bensimon n'est pas le
seul chirurgien à penser que la maladie
d un plan se passe d'abord entre les
deux oreilles avec une caméra cachée
nos collaboratrices sont aller magasiner
des implants auprès des chirurgiens dave
et de catherine
oui j'avais lu sur internet que comme
des femmes qui se plaignent gens de
maladies des implants pour moi c'est
comme une espèce de folie collective à
date et pas de science qui marche la
maladie et quand il j'ai la peau sèche
suite aux divisions abc je développe une
allergie aux tomates voir de quoi il
faut expliquer c'est comment je
comprends pas je pense que c'est
peut-être quelque chose comme alan goise
entre les prothèses se dit angoissé
confronté à ces propos le docteur
chagnon a tenu à fournir de
l'information complémentaire
on parle dans certains articles de la
théorie de la nociception ce que c'est
c'est que l'implant est un stimulus
négatif qui vient alimenter la crainte
que tu es un plan peuvent donner une
maladie qui lui le qui te dis qu'à moi
je suis méchant dans toi ok avec toi se
développent une crainte
une crainte qui va croître de façon
exponentielle et a ordonné soit
développé des symptômes
si la nociception est un risque faut-il
en parler avant l'implantation
je pense qu'on va devoir modifier notre
pratique où effectivement et ajouté
cet élément là dans nos consultations
cet élément de risque
la docteur tracy thompson quant à elle
nous a informés qu'il a commencé à
inclure les risques de maladies auto
immunes dans ses consultations et qu'il
sympathise avec les femmes qui
expérimentent divers symptômes
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les femmes qui
ont des symptômes mais chez qui on
n'arrive pas diagnostiqué une véritable
maladie
on les ignore je pense pas qu'il faut
les ignorer je pense qu'il faut les
prendre en charge eux pensent qu'il faut
les éduquer je pense qu'on est inquiet
pour les éduquer dans l'espace dans le
sens péjoratif bien sûr mais de 2 de
leur apprendre
la physiologie un peu de les renseigner
sur la physiologie je ne sais pas ça
dans ce sens péjoratif du terme
dans moins d'une heure ces femmes seront
à l'afd à elles vont demander la tenue
d'audiences publiques sur les implants
mammaires et le retrait du marché des
implants à surface texturée qui serait
associé à tous les cas de lymphome
répertoriés avec ce métier vous déjà
rencontré les gens de santé canada non
nous n'avons pas réussi à nous asseoir
en face d'eux même si c'est toujours
comme ça que je termine chaque
conversation
est-ce qu'on peut venir à ottawa il ya
quelque chose de foncièrement anormal
vous avez deux canadiennes qui sont
reconnus comme activiste pourtant santé
canada refuse de nous rencontrer
tout ce que nous voulons c'est une
rencontre de quoi ont-ils peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la rencontre avec les représentants de
la sève des ae terminé chacune des 20
femmes a eu quelques minutes pour
présenter son histoire et ses
revendications il y avait vers
représentant de l'afd a et ça cette
fantastique qu'il soit le même nombre
que nous on a fait des centaines
d'heures de travail pour préparer cette
rencontre
je vais adapter les documents et les
envoyer à santé canada mec santé canada
imite l'afd à tout ce qui a été dit
aujourd'hui pourrait s'appliquer à santé
canada depuis deux ans terry talonne
santé canada pour qu'un avis soit envoyé
à toutes les femmes qui ont des implants
texture est susceptible de provoquer un
lymphome achab et je conduis un
chevrolet et quand il ya un problème
potentiel je reçois une lettre de
general motors qui m'incite à passer
chez le concessionnaire il mais comment
ça se fait que janeiro monteuse m'avise
d'un problème avec mon camion et qu'on
ne vise pas d'un problème potentiel avec
un produit qui est dans mon corps les
femmes qui ont des implants textures et
au canada mérite une lettre pas pour les
alarmer mais pour leur dire qu'elles
doivent être à l'affût de certains
symptômes chez les manufacturiers
allergan et mentor ont refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue dans des
déclarations écrites
ils ont tous les deux réitéré que
l'innocuité de leurs produits et est
supporté par de nombreuses études faites
avant et après leur approbation
nos trois anciennes porteuses d'implants
avait des messages pour santé canada
si moi j'avais un souhait c'est que
santé canada a pas fait en 2006 qu'il
soit obligé de la faim maintenant et
j'exigerai immédiatement une étude de 10
à 15 heures sur plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de femmes et l'on verrait au
niveau cité mais qu'est ce qui se passe
avec ses implants leur connaissait pas
quelqu'un plus en santé plus attention
sans fantic mois chez des malades
ça prouve juste que n'importe qui peut
être malade personne est à l'abri j'ai
tellement pensé souvent qu'est ce que je
dirais santé canada ce juste avant face
de moi puis je te jeter encore dans
l'état de colère fait que je les
enverrais probablement promener
alors
je comprends pas comment ces gens ne
peuvent permettre des choses comme ça
mais le foll le docteur cohen terre
verte vient de publier les résultats
d'une étude portant sur 25 mille femmes
elles démontrent clairement que les
porteuses d'implants entre risque accru
de développer des maladies auto immunes
le chercheur pense que des facteurs
génétiques et environnementaux
prédispose certaines femmes à développer
ce type de problèmes a dit m
il est temps de passer à l'action des
choses qu'on devrait faire c'est mettre
au point un test qui permettra de
prévoir qui risque de développer des
problèmes
d'ici là il faut considérer que les
implants ne sont pas sécuritaires
aucune de ces femmes ne milite pour que
tous les implants mammaires soient
retirés du marché mais toutes
revendiquent que les risques potentiels
liés aux implants soit adéquatement
étudier et divulgué je ne veux pas d'
excuses je veux que les femmes qui
seront opérés en sache plus que j'en
savais santé canada nous assure qu'il a
l'intention de rencontrer prochainement
des patientes pour discuter du dossier
lymphome terry aura peut-être bientôt
l'invitation qu'elle attend
est ce que ça valait le voyage
ça fait un moment donné il faut avoir la
foi
on investit du temps on investit de
l'argent et on espère
[Musique]
en terminant je vous mentionne que la
f10 a annoncé récemment qu'elle allait
tenir l'an prochain une grande rencontre
publique avec des conseillers médicaux
dans le but d'analyser les dernières
découvertes scientifiques concernant les
implants c'est tout pour ce soir au nom
de toute l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là et je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]